after looking at game of thrones season
6 more closely for different videos the
more i realize how many devotive logic
aspects there are in the season for this
video we'll go through season 6
chronologically and analyze the most
stupid aspects in each episode so right
away in the beginning david and dan
created a contrived scenario for davos
and friends to get a hold of jon snow's
body because it doesn't make sense why
sir alistair thorne killed jon left his
body and then got mad when davos took
his corpse into a room and barricaded it
if it's causing you this much of a
problem then why didn't you just burn
jon's body on the spot then there's the
whole issue of the logistics of sir
alistar's silly mutiny attempt because
he kind of forgot that the entirety of
the free folk are right outside castle
black and are loyal to jon so they will
immediately lose their control which
very predictably happened if they wanted
to be much smarter about it only have
one person kill jon without implicating
everyone who's against him so that when
they inevitably lose control to the free
folk they won't have an easy time
weeding out all the traitors and there's
one small thing that you shouldn't
really do which is admitting to killing
the lord commander to everyone i did
marsh and awful yahweh and the other
officers in this castle that has to be
the dumbest thing you could possibly do
and it's the exact opposite of what
makes game of thrones so intriguing the
mystery of finding out who kills someone
is infinitely more engaging than openly
admitting to it and is also smarter but
whatever sir alastair and all of his
friends who clearly look scared to die
have a death wish
moving over to theon and sansa's totally
epic escape who couldn't be bothered
with hypothermia end up getting saved by
a convenient brienne wandering around in
the woods
you'd think that during her crusade to
kill stannis in which she both has to
find him in the entire battlefield and
then confront him wouldn't have enough
time to then go and find sansa in the
whole forest because she escaped when
that battle was ongoing and it seems
that brienne finds sanus towards the end
of that battle therefore how would
brienne have enough time to find sansa
or even have the ability to track her
without hounds the only thing that would
make sense would be that brienne heard
the hounds in the forest but we don't
see anything from her perspective so her
entrance feels luck based and is a deus
ex machina to save sansa and theon
then we have the complete [ __ ] storm
which is ellaria sans power grab in
dorne why is it that now suddenly doran
martel has no support from his own
soldiers or kingsguard when a week prior
they gladly arrested elaria sand for
committing treason the sand snakes even
gave the guards a golden opportunity to
flip sides but they seem completely
dedicated to doran if anything that
would be the best time to do the power
grab because there's an additional
target of interest in dorne who's also
captured which was jaime lannister
they'd be able to kill both him and
doran along with myrcella and would be
in a much better position but hey he has
plot armor we'll just let them go and do
the power grab when he's a very safe
distance away and another thing is that
prince tristan was on the boat with
myrcella and jaime and apparently the
sand snakes were on that boat too
although at the end of season 5 they
were clearly on the docks when the boat
left the sandslinks are so forgettable
that even david and dan forgot where
they were in the story so they
conveniently teleported to king's
landing to kill tristain but if we're
going to jump through all those
ridiculous hoops of them teleporting
then why didn't the sand snakes also
kill jaime lannister they waited until
he conveniently left the boat to then
kill prince tristain it's not like jaime
lannister is not all a threat to them
given that he has one hand and can
barely kill anyone so it would be really
easy for the same sex to deal with him
but yeah this was just a very painful
way to set up dorne to be ready for
daenerys alliance which doesn't even
come to the end of the season so i don't
know why david and dan rush this
development so badly now we have some
classic comedy between tyrion and varys
in which [ __ ] jokes make a triumphant
return because you have no [ __ ] all the
more signed that david and dan should
not be writing comedy but besides the
wasted dialogue nothing really happens
here besides the totally pivotal moment
of tyrion wanting to eat babies but at
the end of the scene they find out that
the sons of the harpy had burned down
daenerys's fleet which on multiple
levels is extremely stupid for starters
why aren't there any second sun soldiers
or unsubtly guarding the fleet because
that is single-handedly one of the most
important assets that they own and they
directly need the ships to get to
westeros but apparently they aren't
valuable enough to guard you can make
the argument that the unsullied and
second sons are busy trying to find the
sons of the harpy members of marine but
that alone would be terrible troop
management if there isn't at least a
decent amount of people guarding the
fleet then on the second level of
stupidity how would the sense of the
heart be able to burn down the entire
fleet without anyone noticing during the
process the bells start ringing about 20
seconds before tierne and varus look at
it and by that time every ship is on
fire there's no way that not a single
guard notice any smoke coming from the
bay this really shows the unsullied and
second sons as being extremely unnapped
in the sense of the harvey being very
coordinated and strong when it should be
the other way around yet again though
this scene is another contrived scenario
where daenerys loses her fleet so that
she would gladly accept the alliance of
yara and theon greyjoy offering their
ships
this is just a quick moment that doesn't
make much sense later on but when
daenerys is with the dothraki horde and
is walking with them one of the dothraki
starts to sexually harass her and he
looks pretty familiar since he's one of
daenerys main blood riders in season 7
and 8. so the fact that daenerys doesn't
hold any form of grudge towards him is
kind of surprising given her past
run-ins with people openly harassing her
moving along though during daenerys
confrontation with a new call they
reveal that they don't even know who she
is
this immediately contradicts the ending
of season 5 where they actively solder
out and ambush her with like a thousand
dothraki do they just do this whenever
they see some random helpless girl out
in the middle of nowhere because it came
across as them recognizing her distinct
physical features from afar and actively
seeking her out but nope daenerys was
just unlucky and the entire dothraki is
so horny that they haven't seen a female
in weeks given the amount of resources
they spent trying to capture her
arya has one quick scene where she gets
steamrolled by the waif and it's really
silly that no one tries to help this
poor blind girl getting beaten to death
in public like there are people just
casually watching this happen as if it's
a common occurrence the general
population doesn't have any form of
empathy i guess
episode 2
home i didn't say this at the beginning
of the video but i'll be skipping scenes
that don't have glaring logical issues
and although i have a big problem with
bran's development and what he's been
doing i'll touch on that during the
holder of revelation
in king's landing we have what feels
like a deleted scene that takes place in
flea bottom where amanda's talking about
how cersei saw his dick and she
supposedly licked her lips as a result
of this dreadful slander the mountain
comes out of the shadows like batman and
turns his head into mashed potatoes
there are two things here that
immediately confuse me first why is the
mountain wandering around king's landing
listening to commoners when he should be
guarding cersei like if cersei wants to
be silencing people in the streets
discreetly you can hire literally anyone
else or use other guards besides the
most inconspicuous giant in the king's
guard this work should be way beneath
the mountain then for the next aspect if
you're silencing people who are talking
[ __ ] about you then this guy isn't
really saying anything that damning
given that no one believes his story and
he's coming across as a buffoon who's
drunk then we have the showdown between
jaime lannister and the high sparrow and
i actually really like this scene
however there's one integral line that
has been rendered idiotic thanks to
season seven every one of us is poor and
powerless
and yet together we can overthrow an
empire the high spiral has planted that
seed of information then that together
as a collective they can topple any
dictatorship since they have the sheer
numbers but that whole notion gets
completely erased and this badass line
ends up being weightless in the moment
you can argue that everyone is afraid of
cersei after the great sept explosion
but that isn't even the case given that
everyone seems to love cersei in season
seven and eight and now we get our
episodic dose of terrible comedy with
tyrion making fun of varys for literally
no reason if i lost my [ __ ] i'd drink
all the time it comes across as
exceedingly unprofessional when everyone
is here to discuss problematic issues in
marine but tyrion is over here acting
like a third grader trying to make
adults laugh the comedy in game of
thrones takes a remarkable downturn post
season 5 and the witty jabs at opposing
characters are basically a distant dream
in comparison to the childish humor that
tyrion sadly finds funny and that's just
the start of the scene because the
topics discussed here are laughably
brainless
varus starts by stating that the fleet
has been burned down to which greyworm
replies that no one was guarding the
fleet since there was no witnesses
and wow i was being generous with
assuming that the sons of the harpy were
being very surgical with their attack of
possibly taking out guards but the fact
that there was not a single person at
the bay guarding anything is
mind-boggling
you're telling me that the sons of the
harpy could have stolen the fleet
instead of burning it and no one would
have noticed the unsullied go from being
incompetent to both incompetent and
downright mindless apes that lost all
their brain cells once daenerys left
instead of demanding change for the
unsullied for making this unforgivable
mistake tyrion immediately changes the
conversation to asking for good news is
this what the small castle meetings are
now let's not address the problems at
hand because they make me feel sad then
tyrion sporadically changes the
conversation again to wanting to unchain
the dragons this is not a big issue
given the massive problems they have to
deal with but whatever we're talking
about dragons now because dragons are
cool and city issues are boring oh
what's that the slavers have retaking
assafor and yankai a pressing issue that
demands our immediate attention no the
dragons haven't eaten for a few days so
that's our top priority also tyrion's
plan is to unleash the dragons from
their chains but that doesn't solve
anything because they're still locked
away in a dungeon this problem of the
dragons not eating originated from
daenerys leaving so a random stranger
taking off their chains shouldn't
alleviate that issue and tyrion is
pretty crazy for assuming that some
hungry and angry dragons won't lash out
at him to the dragons he's a complete
stranger and he goes down there alone
with no other friends like missandei to
introduce him to the dragon so that they
identify him as an ally but david and
dan just excuse that nonsense for the
dragons being really smart
although these aren't grown up and are
known to lash out at friendly people let
alone some random small dude who looks
like a chew toy
just forget about all those devoid logic
aspects viewer because tyrion drinks and
he knows things so he's a smart boy
looking at another smart boy we have
ramsay and what was once a smart and
cunning character kind of just evolves
into a crazy lunatic because he wants to
storm the sacred night's watch just to
kill jon
it's wild that the car starks manderlys
and the umbers are fine with that even
though ramsay doesn't end up doing it
but the main person that opposed this
batshit crazy idea was ruse bolton so i
don't know why ramsay randomly drops
this plan when the person opposing it
dies
moving over to brienne she starts to
seem talking about how she had a run-in
with arya in season four
you don't know which way she went i
spent three days looking for her so
again bran isn't in any form of tracker
and it reinforces the notion of finding
sansa in the woods being dumb luck and
speaking of luck it's pretty lucky that
ramsay didn't send more hunters after
sansa after the first party failed they
even seemed to be so confident to be
making a fire at their campsite so they
aren't exactly trying to hide from them
but hey
a drastically high value target isn't
worth more than one attempt to try and
capture like hell they even went through
a complicated plan to kidnap bran by
sending lock in to infiltrate the
night's watch to try and find intel and
bran and to capture him but sending a
second hunting party after one of the
most important people in the north isn't
worth their resources
for the last scene of the episode which
is jon's resurrection there's not a lot
wrong with the scene but there's one
small inconsistency in which melisandre
says she doesn't know how to do the
resurrection
and then turns around and does this
whole fancy ritual indicating that she
doesn't know what to do but let's move
on to episode 3 oath breaker this may be
something that i'm confused by but i
thought that when someone gets
resurrected their past injuries
immediately turn into scars
if jon wakes up with the same wounds
then wouldn't he instantly start
bleeding to death like there are massive
gaping holes in his chest and if he's
alive then there needs to be blood flow
but for some reason he's perfectly fine
also why is this intimate scene of jon
coming back from the dead being spent
with davos of all people a character
that jon doesn't even know and met very
briefly in season 5. if anything he'd
probably be confused as to why he's
there and would want one of his brothers
like ed to be with him to calm him down
so it comes across as david and dan
wanting to ham-fist davos into a higher
position of power next to jon so he's
more relevant to the story then jon
walks outside and not even tormund is
safe from the abhorrent comedy that
david and dan write i saw your pecker
what kind of god would have a pecker
that small
out of all the things to say about
current events he has to say that he has
a small [ __ ] magnificent writing and
ironically the last person who's all the
way in the back of the crowd who
arguably has one of the closer
relationships with jon which is ed
interacts with him last like he seemed
genuinely heartbroken with jon snow's
death and he couldn't even be bothered
to be there with him when he gets
resurrected he's casually just chilling
behind all the extras really i get that
ed isn't a massively influential
character later on in the show and
shouldn't have a ton of screen time but
logically it doesn't make sense for him
to be so absent here also during his
brief dialogue exchange with john he
reintroduces the fact that people change
when they're resurrected by asking him
this
let's tell you in the i don't think so
the fact that this doesn't lead to
anything and jon snow stays the same
character is a complete and utter miss
for jon's character developments like
this was a great opportunity to explore
more worn down jon or introduce new
character traits that pertain to his
resurrection
but nah dave and dan just wanted to use
this resurrection as plot armor to keep
jon stone the story and to have a
cliffhanger finale for season 5.
on the storm he sees we have a scene
between sam and gilly sam surprises
gilly with the information that they
aren't actually going to old town and
are instead going to horn hill on a
decision basis if you are in a
relationship you should probably consult
your significant other before making a
big decision along with the fact that
sam is flat-out lying to gilly they
should be having this conversation
before the boat ride so that if gilly is
extremely upset by sam leaving her she
could voice his concern to him before
getting on the boat to hornhill but sam
doesn't care about what gilly thinks and
would feel because as it stands it seems
like gilly would just be an
inconvenience for him in old town since
all he would have to do is work out
living arrangements for them and that
shouldn't be that big of a problem and
it isn't that big of a problem in season
seven so by sam wanting to ditch gilly
that should definitely upset her and
there would be a much larger argument
here but david and dan write it so that
gilly just doesn't care and since
there's a lack of conflict the scene
ends early because of that their
relationship feels so superficial and
after this point i could really care
less about them also why is sam even
bothering with the idea of bringing a
wildling to his home both his father
hates his guts and there's no way he'll
want a house a wildling in his home due
to how conservative he is and how does
sam intend on explaining this whole
situation if he's in a nice watch and it
isn't supposed to be with anyone he'd
immediately come off as forsaking his
oath in front of his family and would be
a complete embarrassment so the fact
that sam even thinks this is a good idea
and would rather deal with that [ __ ]
storm instead of taking care of gilly
himself is mental
looking into the past we have a flashy
action scene and to be honest i'll let
this one slide because of how cool it
was initially but it does fall into the
action conundrum of facing multiple
people at once and one person attacking
at a time like if the men were down to
break honor and stop sir arthur dane in
the back then why didn't they do so
early or not let all their friends die
whatever let's move on to another
riveting tyrion comedy extravaganza
for this scene it feels like it's a
deleted scene and it only exists to make
the episode past the 50 minute mark
despite two minutes of dialogue it's
kind of baffling that dave and dan
couldn't muster a single line that
offered some form of character
development the only thing we learned is
that missandei and greyworm don't drink
and that's it tyrion is still acting
like a child and wants to play games
with two very serious people and for
some reason tyrion can't act more mature
and talk to adults in a more witty
manner maybe it would be nice to relate
past trauma and hardships you guys have
gone through together instead of
blabbering on about alcohol we do not
drink
until you do
the pure contrast of season six tyrion
to season two and three tyrion is crazy
it's like his mind is developing
backwards like benjamin button then we
have a small council meeting where
maester pysel farts for comedic relief
and i think i need to highlight this
moment this is game of thrones one of
the most serious and dark shows that
have shocked audiences and we are now
devolving to the lowest form of comedy
of farting seriously we are down this
bad to succumb to this david and dan
these are emmy award-winning writers and
this is what they are writing into these
episodes besides the egregious fart not
much really happens here and all the
adults themselves are acting childish
too by refusing to work with each other
there's only a couple of other small
aspects wrong with the episode like the
umbers randomly giving up rick on stark
for free but i don't feel like that
needs much elaboration at this pace
though i'll probably be doing three
devoted logic videos on season six i
know i only did one on season seven but
back then i basically just cherry picked
the most stupid aspects instead of doing
a more thorough chronological analysis i
hope you guys enjoyed the video and also
thank you guys for getting the channel
to 300 000 subscribers
that's crazy
[Music]
you